[Music]
up next is rebecca out of portland hey
rebecca welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
i'm about to be engaged and i need
advice if i should stay with my
boyfriend
[Laughter]
you have called the right place
it's a lot of pressure oh my gosh you're
rebecca so oh my gosh give us the story
rebecca what is happening so you're
about to be engaged you know this
rachel has never missed an episode
rachel has never missed an episode of
the bachelor
we have got you
okay go for it go for it so
we've been dating for a year and a half
my boyfriend is a recovering addict he's
four years sober
a month ago he elapsed back into youth
fast forward to last night
and i find i found out that he still has
ten thousand dollars in medical debt
that i thought he had paid off anytime
we've talked about those two situations
he's ended the conversation by saying i
knew i shouldn't have told you about it
i love this man fiercely but i'm really
scared right now and i need some advice
yeah
so
a couple of things
let me like so
he struggles with addiction okay that
for me isn't a reason to say i'm out
right and for your sobriety and having a
rough day or
you know taking some steps back
that's something that if you choose to
engage in a marriage you know what
you're getting into and you've probably
got addictive tendencies of your own and
we're going to work through this
together
the part that has given me some
significant pause that i think is this
the killer of relationships is secrets
this idea that i'm going to have an
alternative life underneath my marriage
and i'm gonna have things that i keep in
my drawers that she doesn't know about
or he doesn't know about
and secrets there's a biology to secret
secrets kill you and they kill
relationships and so there's a deception
and dishonesty here i'm hiding stuff
from you right that's the part that
man i think your instincts
not saying you need to call this thing
off
but um i think there needs to be a um
truth-telling time like no more secrets
no more
i don't like that impulse i knew i
shouldn't have told you yeah because
rebecca though and why anybody says that
is it because you if you can like be
self-aware enough to know are you
defensive about like are you coming do
you fly off the handle get mad at him is
it like that or is it you're just asking
questions and trying to care for him and
he still has that reaction like what
what are those conversations like
i'm a pragmatist so when we have those
kinds of conversations i listen and then
i try to
like find a solution so that
conversation last night
ended because
he he said you know um this debt is old
it's not affecting my credit score
anymore
i don't have to deal with it that the
collectors aren't calling me anymore and
i said it's still debt you need to pay
it off
did you you said when you were talking
to us that you thought it was gone did
you think it was gone because the story
you told yourself or did he lie to you
that's a great question i
i'm
if i remember correctly
i'm pretty sure he told me he paid it
off or at least that's how it how it
came across that he wasn't in debt
anymore so the language you're using
right now suggests you all might be in a
pretty common relational pattern as
people often marry or get
get into relationship with people who
struggle with addiction
because they are fixers or in your words
you're pragmatists
and i want you to be very careful about
seeing him as somebody to fix
instead of somebody to be with
and often he may come to you with i need
just to listen to me i want you to hear
me
i'm struggling i'm hurting and he's not
asking for what do i do next he's
probably a really smart guy that's had
to be pretty self-reflective to have
gone through four years of sobriety he
really needs his fiance his girlfriend
his wife his partner his best friend to
sit with him and just say this sucks can
i hold your hand
that makes sense all this is saying you
all need to have a couple of hard no
more secrets truth-telling conversations
and he may have more secrets like here's
what i need i need you to not try to fix
me
and you may have secrets like i need you
to never lie to me never hold withhold
from me
or this relationship's not going to work
you're going to run into a brick wall at
some point right
what's the what's the probability of him
relapsing
oh i i mean i think that would be
anybody's going to give you that kind of
i don't know i don't know him i don't
know what the what he's struggling with
there's no way to say that right and i
think your pragmatist wants a percentage
right like is it a 42 or a 17.7 but also
for her sake though
walking into
a lifelong committed relationship with
someone
what what is that how do you walk down
that path knowing i'm going to choose
someone which everyone everyone's broken
right like i mean
yeah it comes out in different ways but
cocaine is different than heroin that's
different than alcohol it's different
than pornography that's different from
smoking right so
and trauma is different than people who
work 140 hours a week so it's so if
you're going into a relationship with
knowing this though for her sake
what are the questions you would be
asking
what are the things that you dig into
for her to to her philosophy because i'm
hearing from you rebecca because i'm not
a trained therapist this is why i have
john next to me is i'm like okay if i if
he's been four years that's amazing and
i'm going to celebrate that but he's
he's gone down once is he going to go
down now every single week for the rest
of our marriage you know what i mean
like you kind of go down that road
and what do you do what what is it and
that's it's an anxiety it's trying to
grab control i want to figure out the
next thing
exactly so here's what we're going to do
we're going to focus on a set of core
agreements that we're going to um all be
a part of and
towards a life that we want to build
right so when you sit down with a
builder and you say i want to use the
top
of the top cabinets i want the top of
the then they're going to go shop and
get them right so you all are going to
create a series of relational boundaries
and actions and agree to them this is
who we are
we are always going to tell the truth
even if you have a relapse you're going
to tell the truth you will never hide
things from me and that means when you
need something different from the way
i'm treating you you got to tell me
because that's a secret that's a lie if
you don't tell me and i promise to right
so y'all are going to create a series of
behaviors that you will commit to
and that you will double down on and
then you will deal with life as it comes
right and that that i think we focus so
much on the goals and the outcomes if
you have one more cigarette i'm out of
here
why is that person have to smoke maybe
we've created a home that's so tense and
so toxic and so hard and not dealing
with old stuff right so let's create an
ecosystem where we can both survive and
live that's right and so let's start
there but i think it starts with
everybody sitting down in a room and
looking at each other and says time to
be honest time to turn the lights on
let's be honest so good thanks for the
call rebecca this is the ramsay show